hey it's dr. Berg here in this video
we're gonna talk about how to raise
testosterone in men okay so age the
aging process alone lowers testosterone
by the time you hit 40 testosterone is
on its way down it's at its peaked at 18
years old okay
so and then what happens a lot of people
start taking bio identical hormones the
problem taking valid in a hormone is
that it inactivates your own testicle
and adrenals that are supposed to make
it okay so we end up creating a problem
with shrinking testicle and an adrenal
that becomes an activator if you take it
too long
the symptoms for a low testosterone
would be prostate enlargement now
sometimes people will have this
confusion and say that well I thought
testosterone causes a prostate
enlargement and they're talking about a
powerful form of testosterone called DHT
well first of all if testosterone causes
a prostate enlargement then as you get
older and men have more incidence of
prostate enlargement then that does not
correlate with the aging process that
lowers testosterone so really what
happens it's the lower testosterone that
makes the estrogen become more so it's
the estrogen dominance in a male body
that creates the enlargement of the
prostate in fact certain doctors use DHT
to shrink the prostate so more
testosterone will make the prostate
healthier and protect the prostate
against the estrogen decreased libido
erectile dysfunction we talked about
this shrinking testes muscle loss it's
hard to get muscle tone you're working
out you can't get the tone toning the
muscles you start losing collagen things
start hanging from your body like breast
tissue and the skin and collagen loss of
vitality loss of body hair even in your
like lower part of your legs manboobs
higher voice other than that you have
nothing to worry about right okay what
causes this problem number one too much
it's in the it's in the meets it's in
the very products it's in the food GMO
food that's why you have to do organic
hormone-free it's even in the water
supply there's estrogen if you do tap
water so that's so you'd have to get a
filter and only drink filtered water and
most filters will get rid of the
estrogen but yeah it's you know it's in
the water supply having liver be damaged
if you have a fatty liver
you're gonna produce more estrogen and
that's going to lower testosterone
unfortunately if you drink alcohol
that's very Astra genic that's gonna
make the estrogen go up in the
testosterone go down I'm sorry but
that's the way it is high insulin
insulin from sugar like grazing at night
snacking too much like by the time you
have dinner then you keep eating from
that point where you're sitting there
watching TV it's gonna spike insulin and
it's going to lower testosterone so you
want to do 3 meals a day and that's it
maybe even two meals a day low-fat diets
that'll do it
medications statins high blood pressure
medications diabetic medications those
are the three that really mess with this
hormone and this other thing called high
aromatisse that's an enzyme in your body
that's made by the adrenals it's also
made by the testes that converts your
testosterone to estrogen so here you are
trying to salvage that last bit of
testosterone you have and this darn
enzyme is converting it to estrogen and
the body is becoming more feminized well
there's a couple things that you can do
to correct that number one this remedy
called stinging nettle root
it's a aromatase inhibitor okay
zinc is a row mateus inhibitor you can
take those to decrease this process
happening in your liver in your body so
those are two good remedies that you can
get from the health of store the other
thing is to increase growth hormone
growth hormone is anti-aging hormone
growth hormone is made by the pituitary
and it works through your liver
wherever growth hormone goes
testosterone follows so there's there's
several things that will increase growth
from them eating a moderate not high
amount of protein with each meal sleep
getting enough sleep lowering stress
which will enhance the sleep intense
full body and exercise that will spike
growth hormone spike testosterone
deadlifts are the best workout to
increase testosterone because you're
using the upper body and lower about it
but you have to get your form down and
work up very gradually or you could hurt
your back intermittent fasting okay that
will also correct the insulin right here
so not eating so frequent will help this
as well that's interesting
the hope the whole thing is it's like I
don't know who came up with this idea we
have to have three meals a day or six
meals a day you kind of want to eat when
you're hungry if you eat the right
things you're gonna be more satisfied
you'll work off your own fat and you'll
need to eat less but you never want to
eat if you're not hungry
okay anti-estrogen ik foods that would
be cruciferous okay kale broccoli
brussel sprouts cabbage very very
important to clean out the estrogen
because it could be the estrogen that's
holding down your testosterone if you
want something to enhance that I have a
product called whole cruciferous food it
has all the cruciferous you take about
six of these three to six a day and that
will help you in to enhance these
cruciferous foods and then you want to
decrease cortisol cortisol the stress
hormone from the adrenals and that is
kind of depending on the house so much
sleep that you get but also Sun I had
this guy he had this potbelly and all
you have to do is go to Florida for one
week in the Sun and it just comes right
down it's amazing so a good amount of
Sun lowers cortisol that will help
shrink the belly as well so that's
another remedy yes you can do vitamin D
in the winter
if you can get some Sun that would help
lower in cortisol okay
so these are just some tips to help you
enhance this hormone so put your
comments below thanks for watching